I'll do it wired Jeff Nichols scene one
take one
growing up in Arkansas we always used to
see southern films and and examples of
southern people in movies and it just
never really rang true to me when I set
out to start to make contemporary
southern films I just made rules for
myself I would never have a score with
any banjo in it if people tried to
effect any accent I would just crush it
I didn't really know what I was doing at
that point I just was kind of going on
instinct and my instincts were to try
and reflect things around me as honestly
as possible obviously if you're making a
revenge film which is what shocking
stories is you're gonna have violence in
it but I felt like at the time that I
was making this film violence was
treated almost as an art form the way
you would choreograph these violent
scenes it seemed to be dishonest you
know I've only gotten in a few fights of
my life and I've always been really
really ugly and not at all cool I've
been really fortunate to shoot all my
films on film I just like the kind of
organic nature of it one of the problems
with film is in dark low-light
situations it betrays itself you start
to have to bring in a lot of extra
lights just in order to get an exposure
for this particular scene I was really
aggressive with my cinematographer we
were sealed off in this shipping
container and I said look here's the
deal we're only gonna like this with
this one Coleman camping lantern if you
look there's a little bit of light on
the floor I let them put one light back
there and to this day I hate it a lot of
people that hate the ending that movie
in fact the people that really love this
movie that hate the ending in that movie
I'm not really big on plot I think plots
a little overrated I don't really care
about Indians either what I care about
as a filmmaker is taking emotion and
transferring it to the audience
it's really tough making movies and so I
feel like if you can wrap your hands
around a palpable feeling in the script
face and get it all the way through this
gauntlet of a filmmaking process then I
think you're successful any better than
that
snake won't cross the barrier rope
Thanks I'm terrified of snakes I've been
scared of snakes my whole life I was in
junior high on a church retreat
trip and I was speaking to this older
gentleman who was a Cherokee and he told
me this story about putting a braided
rope around your bed at night and that
snake won't crawl over a braided rope
when you write characters you build
belief systems for them and muds belief
system is one built out of superstition
he doesn't really traffic in the truth
very often I thought that was kind of an
important foundational element of his
character mom is talking about moment in
town what's that mean she seemed set on
it
I'm separate I'm an ask for divorce when
I write men especially southern men I
like to try and subvert cliche as much
as I can
this father you know you've come home
and he's drinking and he's kind of a
gruff guy you think this scene could
maybe turn in him being mean to the boy
or rough with him but that's not where
it goes at all in fact here it is this
patriarch of this family and he talks
about his failures as a man in addition
to the fact that his world is just
crumbling around him but for me it's
really about this father showing his
weaknesses it's time you ready yeah
okay I don't know where I got this from
but it was probably an urban legend I
heard that in Arkansas they used to run
drugs in the middle of the night and the
way they would do it is get really fast
souped-up cars turn all the lights off
and then put on night-vision goggles I
have no idea if that's true but it
sounded cool and it felt like a cool way
to open a movie so I kind of designed
this this opening that would put these
guys on a very fast trajectory in the
middle of the night with no lights on it
seemed to kind of I don't know summarize
this feeling that the title kind of
summarizes - like a midnight drive-in
movie a sci-fi movie I might have grown
up on like et or Close Encounters or
Starman a critique of a lot of my films
is that they're slow and I suppose they
are
but with this film I wanted to make a
film as propulsive I wanted to make a
chase movie in order to do that I would
build this massive story all of these
things happen in the beginning all of
these things happening at the end and
then I would just lop off both sides of
those and we would just start in the
middle I think it kind of activates the
audience's mind they're immediately
starting to ask these questions trying
to connect these dots and that was the
goal of midnight special I think I would
have done really well in like the 1950s
or 1940s in the film industry I think I
I would have gone out to LA I think I
would have studied under other directors
and tried to find some ladder to climb
up but that's not the world we live in
now I'm a director because I directed a
movie and if I have any advice for
people it would be go write something go
direct it if that's what what you
haven't decided to go do it
you know if the movie stinks just put it
on the shelf and then try and do it
again